on va démarrer par
le président non le président des faux
culs est-ce que vous avez des intuitions
vous oh bah oui
si je pense que là je pense que l'on va
beaucoup voir gilles verdez
castaldi
ok
ben jama
c'est la même personne
valérie bénaïm
vainqueur
benjamin
je rappel c'est le président des faux
culs celui qui parle dans le dos des
zones à oui non c'était ça ou je croyais
président déçu certes ce changement sera
fragile
autres benjamins et il parle beaucoup
dans le dos des zones tout le temps
genton
géraldine
genton encore deux ans points d'avancé
castany je m'inscrivais de cellules son
verdict of
terrible et enfin que takashi l'ignoble
faux culs
daniel tu m'excite je vois pas
alors madame un casse a dit vous avez
été élu président des faux cul ça veut
dire que vous parlez sur les autres dans
les loges très bien je défonce tout le
monde serait terrible mois sauf vous
évidemment away est ce que je voulais
témoigner ce qui me défonce la
maintenance avait jamais vraiment le
reste oui oui c'est vrai il dit quoi ai
dit quoi du coup j'ai dit la vérité que
j'ai des tas crétin
que lui csti sa pub à ses yeux
alors pour baisser les yeux faudra en
avoir
c'est vrai qu'on a on ajoutera d'autres
séquences on se chambre beaucoup les
années passées c'est toujours pour le
boulonnais d'arcachon mais c'est vrai je
me devrai me myriam alors je le dis
c'est vraiment il s'éclate on loge en
cours d'école mais je vous dis j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une classe de 6ème
et je suis à côté moi dans ma loge
j'entends des bruits d'eau fumée est
sortie on sait comme la prof principal
qu'est ce qui se passe
et je vous jure j'entends des bruits de
route dans la loggia côté c'est parce
qu'ils font des couilles je suis pas là
depuis longtemps mais c'est vrai que
c'est une cour de
rexel c'est n'importe quoi c'est
n'importe quoi je président du bouquet
daniel pour le bien de l'émission sont
baladés savoir j'aurais peut-être les
bons
avec plaisir
sur tous les tableaux guillaume à
françoise est imparfait chernicoff
c'est
un
très bon gars mais clément j'adore les
mecs ont mis le nom finit bien
guillaume vient de partout au canada
genton
mois guillaume daniel revient ma petite
niche copé
cholet
truc à lui dire je suis très content ce
que daniel tu as un petit bull qui ne
laisse pas indifférent
voilà mais en fait avec ce corps à corps
que j'ai vu il est simple et un petit
truc tu pourrais peut-être me bouille
avait dans la piscine
[Rires]
salle ont commencé ça m'a un petit peu
excité la théorie c'est
la viande bas c'était encore rapports 7g
te dise
exactement c'était pas mal pour lui ça
lui a coûté quand même
[Rires]
attention à nos présidents des six
heures à doit-on vraiment dépouillés
j'ai ça démarre comme je l'entendais
gilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bernicot fta
vaucluse side
gilles c'est
valérie bénaïm or ce que tombe
gilles l'ignoble suceurs de sang
janier danijel ljuboja
jill aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe ça se précise
c'est un trio s'est unaniment la
plébiscitent pernikoff
unanime ray
mais naïma
et enfin c'est un succès de gide et
crade horaires des vernets
basile pour votre victoire oui merci
c'est le vote des aigris et des jaloux
il me détourneront pas de mon amour pour
vous ma merci j'ai une maman aussi nous
détourneront jamais de mon amour pour
vous merci s'il vous savez comme je vous
aime
voilà bah merci en tout cas le président
voilà si vous deviez élire un président
du chroniqueur ce serait qu'il faut
castaldi srecki pour vous le président
américain d'accord toujours beaucoup
d'humilité célèbre une minute et de plus
en plus minimes mathieu mathieu -
aujourd'hui ben
non moi
bien garni kof je vais être prudent
géraldine parce que je sais
moi je dirais guillaume bravo oui moi je
prendrais clément parce que c'est
l'avenir vous dépendrez valérie parce
que c'est david maman ça lui fait
plaisir d'être sur
toi pour laguiole non mais bon adjoumani
bah oui l'aja tout faire pour quitter la
bretagne et le mot
déjà la fille du prendre la gueule alors
la maman là je peux te dire tu rentres
chez toi là c'est à dire tu vas direct à
la clinique des champs elysées à
la balle à tuchan listings conduit
alors qu'ici on parle pas sur les autres
parce qu'on vous le faisait ce qu'on
voulait acheter l'équipe télématin
haoussa voilà
voilà mais ici ici c'est ici et des
règles non je te le dis ma belle je lis
pas parce que tout le monde votre
brouillard qu'il fonctionne
mathieu parce que j'adore ta venue ah
oui un bon point mais non mais clément
où
il est arrivé tout timide là je m'en
bats les clubs
mais clément match mais votre style
ouais ouais bah ouais pour pas mal
qu'est ce qui vous plaît en lui ben il
fait pas son âge mais alors sinon ben
voilà tout simplement il n'est pas mal
non parce que disons qu'il n'y est pas
alors à java daniel moreau vous a marqué
il a toujours dit je louvre le journal
qu'elle veuille à pâtisser avez vous
tout à fait d'accord ah oui ouais
d'accord ah ouais m'intéressait ya une
peur banana split on prend les trois
verts il est ouvert mais ils ont fermé
la raison c'est bien mon art ou clément
sait que c'est que tout comme mon petit
frère 1 il le sait j'ai dirigé je ne
lâcherai pas elle m'a vu naître
exactement gros de naître voilà vous moi
je vais évidemment pour valérie parce
qu'elle est conscient suel elle est
raisonnable
alors attention avec le délégué de saas
doit pouvoir on a way s'est lancé après
je lançais oui le le le
qui peut faire ça si on prend quelqu'un
qui n'a pas de personnalité
d'après lui le [ __ ]
ouais moi je vote pour gilles parce que
même si c'est un ignoble [ __ ] doublé
d'un faux cul pour mathieu meilleurs
chroniqueurs et de loin
pas mentir je suis je suis d'accord il
est très sympa à cerny de monsieur ça